hello hello
hello yourself uh david uh the pac-man
pac-man happy to be talking to you it's
great to be on with you again
uh truly an honor how you doing i'm
doing well i'm doing well how was your
thanksgiving
it was great we um
i through a contrivance got to see my
family earlier in the month so i didn't
see them this time we just um a
contrivance is that legal
uh shouldn't be i got baited into
heading down to la for a jubilee
appearance but it turns out it got
cancelled after i booked the flight so
my parents are there anyway you know so
oh i see do you say where you're based
regularly
oh i'm in seattle oh okay oh so
literally down the coast
yeah gotcha gotcha and what are you on
planes are you like doing full n95 or
just like one of the cloth masks
um just uh just a you know a
rotating series of disposable masks i
never found a cloth one that looks good
with a beard i don't know if i ever
could find one that looks good with a
beard oh i see that i say
are you like when you're on a plane do
you feel like you're more at risk of
catching it or on a plane you feel safe
um
honestly i don't feel that at risk on a
plane because it's you know airports and
airplanes are one of the few
institutions that actually seem to take
seriously the whole wiping down every
surface that kind of thing
um
yeah i don't know i feel more at risk at
like a grocery mark than i do on a plane
but that's just oh that's interesting
see i have a bit of a different
perspective i mean i don't feel too at
risk on the plane but not because
they're wiping down surfaces because it
seems like that actually is not really
how people are catching this it's more
just like you're near someone who has it
and you're breathing the same air
but because of the
very high efficacy
air filtration and mandatory masks
that's a good point yeah i forgot about
the air filtration they'd have to keep
that standard up there i do still hate
flying though honestly covet is the
least of my worries i just hate
heights so
it's just
um
i'm not a big fan um you know as for the
concept do you medicate on the flight
uh no no i i try not to i know people
who have to take ambien or whatever but
i usually just stock up on um
on on audio you know audiobooks i
haven't listened to or podcasts or
whatever the hell else and uh just try
to live through it i gotcha yeah yeah i
know i know people who take uh sedatives
when they fly stuff like that
or they just drink if in first class
right they usually just give you wine
you can get enough of that i mean that
might help sure oh are you flying in
first class i've only flown in first
class once somebody else was paying for
it and i didn't like them so i just went
with first class and uh booked it to
them oh that's a good move that's a
beautiful move
yeah it's um it's the the only time i
would you know afford myself that
indulges if if if economy is good enough
for bernie it's good enough for me right
well i'm seeing pictures of him up front
too but i guess that's a story for a
different day
he varies a little bit getting
complacent his old age
so are you now on thanksgi are you uh do
you eat turkey is that a big thing for
you
uh i hate i know turkey's like the worst
meat no i um no we well okay this time
we just had mac and cheese it was
disgustingly rich mac and cheese i got
some tarts and some pies you know um but
normally no i'm i'm more of a stuffing
bread roll pecan pie
uh you know food coma type of guy mm-hmm
oh you uh yeah i had some turkey i had
some turkey i mean it's like you know
it's always kind of dry and like you're
really counting on it's really about the
quality of the
um gravy quite frankly that because th
you know turkey breast it's like it is
what it is you know
yeah there's only
so much you can do to shoe [ __ ] up i
think did you did you what would you
celebrate with like uh
oh with family with family
okay gotcha yeah yeah just uh yeah it
was just me and my roommates um but you
know the
family uh you know very flexible term
whoever you're with uh can be your
family on thanksgiving it's a magic of
the holiday are your roommates um
sort of like i'm guessing you're the
most famous of the people you live with
is that a fair assumption
yeah i guess so do they take are they
resentful of your fame
uh i maybe they would be if i made them
pay rent but honest to god i feel like
they're getting the i feel like they're
getting the good end of the deal on this
one oh you pay for their rent
that that'll that only seems fair right
you know like i don't know
i don't know what this what the
circumstances are
i would i would never i'd feel like such
an [ __ ] you know like uh you know oh
yeah you know you've got you've got this
arrangement that and the other and we're
all going to split it three ways and
then i you know watch them like pull out
the the coins they've got buried in the
back of their wallet to try to make rent
oh do you want do you own the place is
that the situation no no oh you don't
know we're all world-renting you're all
renting okay oh i see
you're not like rent seeking or
something like that
i know as far as my audience knows you
know we're all renting i would never
become a landlord wouldn't yeah as far
as my audience knows okay i got you very
very good we'll check the property
records later and determine exactly the
arrangement there
um just try to catch me yeah
uh okay good well so oh on the flying
thing i did want to ask is it do you not
like the discomfort of it or is it
you're worried the plane will crash
um
i think it's shifted more with time
because when i was younger i was just
terrified of crashing um and i still
don't like that you know but now i think
the physical discomfort is the worst bit
by far okay um the the seats are so tiny
and i'm a decently big guy you know oh
is that right how tall a guy are you
i'm i'm six too and i've got wide hips
so they they bridge up against the um
the the little armrests like on the
sides but you can't lift them if you're
next to a stranger of course oh i had no
idea you were six too because in the in
the infamous picture of you sitting next
to stephen kenneth destiny bonnell ii
you guys are sitting down and it's hard
to tell relative size
yeah and you know out of respect i try
to like you know lean down a little bit
like yeah yeah
you're slouching down just to not
impress people too yeah i know what
you're saying that's good that's polite
yeah yeah just common etiquette i think
i think so um
the la the last five
before we talk about anything serious
the last flight that i had was was
utterly miserable i had i had a headache
the the duration of the return flight
but um there the woman directly in front
of me this older lady who didn't speak
english only spanish and she actually
had like a medical emergency she
couldn't breathe that well so you know
they brought out the oxygen tank they
did the holes they're a doctor on board
thing and i actually with a headache got
to like have 40 minutes of people
swarming next to me like elbowing me in
the side of the head as they shuffle
around the woman directly in front she
was fine she was fine you know now when
they ask for a doctor
on a plane i wonder if people stand up
and say i'm a doctor but i mean i'm a
doctor in sociology or in that context
is it known that they only want a
medical doctor
you know i'm actually really proud of my
uh flight guests because it seems like
every one of them got the the
connotation you know i knew they wanted
a medical doctor you know one of them
stood up and was like yeah you know i've
got a i've got a doctorate in in
mathematics
yeah uh this shit's work
uh so i'm proud of them maybe maybe the
next flight though it's funny because
there everybody knows exactly what
they're looking for my dad has had
situations where he actually is a doctor
but a psychiatrist and he'll wait
because he knows when they're asking for
a doctor
they'd rather it not be a psychiatrist
so he'll usually wait but then if it's
like nobody steps forward then he'll be
like i'm a doctor okay
yeah because that's better than nothing
exactly it's better than yeah that's
you still a few definitely a few steps
up above the average person sure i mean
it is a medical doctor but you know yeah
yeah but you know you could probably
like i don't know look at people's
eyeballs and get something from that
their state of being how they're feeling
i don't know it's it's it's something
well this thing was very simple it was
someone was having a food allergic
reaction of some kind and they had so
you don't really see shrimp that often
on planes but they had shrimp and then
it was like oh i think i might be
allergic to shrimp and my dad just had
to say i have to find out
do you guys have
benadryl in your like medical kit and
they were like yeah and he was like i'd
probably give him a benadryl i don't
know and then the guy was fine
okay well good good thing it didn't
require one of those epipens right
exactly exactly yeah
so listen what are we talking about
today oh um
my my as my resident
favorite uh liberal i wanted to talk
with you a little bit about rittenhouse
oh okay all right
um yeah so i mean we you cover the trial
obviously all the trial that i saw was
through your stream beautiful i know you
were in there leaving very powerful
super chats
yeah um
and you were you were there uh very
powerfully leaving the stream for hours
at a time collecting revenue uh well i
did have work to do i had to plan my
next show you know
ah oh you know well not all live
streamers have that privilege you know i
actually have to i rush back from the
bathroom after peeing uh to keep viewers
but no it's fair
um okay so as for the legal outcome you
know i i get it uh i i understand where
you know where that all came from uh
morally still don't think that she
should have been there i don't think
that's uh she
he oh sorry sorry sorry uh i i've read
so many memes about written house
transitioning to own the libs uh that's
affecting me um but you know i i've seen
how that went have you had the pleasure
of seeing the tucker carlson interview
yes i have
what did you think of that
well i mean listen um
oh god so so i i feel like i have to
issue 10 disclaimers like the opinion
i'm going to give has nothing to do with
the verdict i get the verdict it's the
verdict i expected etc so so like i'm
just going to talk about the interview
as an interview
um
i thought it was part of the predictable
lies lionization and making a hero out
of the guy i i mean that that's if you
want my one line analysis it's that i
did think it was interesting when he
says i support black lives matter
um you know a lot has been made of that
was a calculated lie he doesn't really
support them or he very narrowly said i
support their right to demonstrate and
that it was like now i don't know you
know okay he said he supports black
lives matter it might well be true it
wasn't like the most interesting part of
it for me
but for me it was like you know the
beginning of the very predictable hero
tour where then he met with trump and
they did the pictures with the thumbs up
and the whole thing it's just part of
the whole media tour
oh yeah for sure i i i've been seeing a
lot of mixed reactions online because i
know there were a ton of conservatives
who wanted rittenhouse to be this like
ride or die angel of mega conservatism
you know where he'd go up there and he'd
screech like let's go brandon and tucker
cross and do the okay sign and then like
you know uh
talk about trans bathrooms
when i was watching the interview you
know he came off
most to me like a really like partisan
republican like talking points you'd
hear from uh from from like a you know a
pundit when talking about self-defense
and the trial specifically oh i agree
the moment specific sorry to interrupt
the moment where i knew this was like so
calculated and coached and it's okay to
be coached i'm not saying it's bad
being prepared for an interview okay uh
was where he started to say
it's the moment where he says the trial
wasn't about kyle rittenhouse it was
about self-defense and then he says if i
was guilty
no one would be able and then he goes no
no no
he he goes
no one would be privileged and it's like
that's the language his lawyer used
that's the language his lawyer used you
know
that's i feel like that was absolutely
you know where the the
soviet spy um conditioning kicked in or
whatever you know where he was um most
trying to deliver a point because i felt
like in contrast the rest of the
interview he came off relatively
measured you know i'm not here singing
his praises or anything i'm not saying
he you know came off like a
hero of the revolution but oh god hold
on
there we go oh my god what was that that
sounded like a gerbil
no i it's
coffee i i have cinnamon on top okay
okay okay
um but but um not to sing his praises or
anything like that but um for the rest
of it it felt to me like he was sort of
passively rejecting a lot of the stuff
that i would expect him to cash in on
you know he said that the left and the
right had both exploited him for
political gain
um over the course of the trial you know
he seems to be uninterested in these
showboat-y you know marjorie
taylor-green bobert you know gazar
attempts at getting him as some kind of
staffer and that's interesting to me you
know because i i feel like a lot of
people on the right were let down you
know they wanted him to be
the the emblem of of everything they've
been screeching about for the past 18
months
i totally agree with that and i thought
um again
whether it was calculated or not
i actually think that he
i don't know i mean there you know you i
don't know how much you looked at the
online sphere in reaction and there were
a lot of people furious about his blm
comment and a lot of people who didn't
think he was quote tough enough when
given the opportunity to send a message
to joe biden or whatever the case may be
but there was a lot of that stuff where
it seems like the the perspective is
um just kind of say something to appease
anyone who wants to be appeased because
the people who want to be mad will be
mad either way
yeah yeah for sure because my my the
advice that i've given at this point is
that at least to my audience you know
you can't take any of this seriously
anymore um
if you take it seriously you know like
if you take it with with great gravitas
you know oh written house this that or
the other you know you come off like a
sore loser
now
rittenhouse himself acknowledged that if
he was black he might not have been
given the same prosecutorial privileges
that he was given being a white guy
which i thought was interesting but uh i
i feel like now that we're like on the
other side of the verdict it's
irresponsible because i've seen this
somewhere in online spaces you know to
go oh well he only got off because of
white supremacy or all right because of
this or the other because
you can't really substantiate that stuff
directly even though it's sociologically
omnipresent and it makes you come off
like you know like a sore loser like uh
you know oh you only won because you
cheated you know um how do you feel
about that i actually i mean i have not
uh
i don't know that i mentioned white
supremacy during the trial other than
the controversy over the picture which
was not admitted as evidence
um but have people been saying after the
fact that the verdict is a result of
white supremacy i didn't even hear that
i just i not i don't think through
official sources more just like um
people getting angry on twitter a couple
of viral tweets stuff like that i think
because if a conservative sees that
right i mean it must be pretty
reaffirming you know like ridden house
wins and then the left engages in
behavior that to them reinforces the
idea that the left will call anything
racist if they don't like the outcome um
same with the same with the stuff with
the you know the interview with tucker
carlson you know i think it's quite
funny this ideological dissonance i
think between the party and
rittenhouse's behavior post verdict um
but if you look into it too hard
i feel like you're opening yourself up
for a lot of disappointment i'm just i'm
just kind of hoping that something
you know really funny happens in the
future like he gets into a beef with
some conservative like prominent
conservative who says that he's not
living up to their expectations i think
that'd be very funny yeah or i mean
there's always the chance that like like
well do you remember the george
zimmerman trayvon martin case
when that was done it was pretty obvious
that this was not the end of zimmerman's
legal troubles and indeed it wasn't with
written house i actually do think
now he seems to be better advised he
actually may stay out of trouble
indefinitely whereas with zimmerman it
seemed like the guy was so out of
control that it was bound to get you
know and he had a domestic violence
issue and some other issue i actually
don't know
that that's likely to happen with
written house
yeah i think i agree i i would be very
surprised if he ever does anything like
that again you know not not because i
think he's undergone this gigantic
ideological shift he just doesn't seem
to mean like the kind of person
who's
predisposed towards
violence i guess i could say like like
it's it seems at least from his behavior
maybe that's
how he's shaped up since then that
whatever decision-making led him to go
and do his vigilante bit over at kenosha
it was was more or less circumstantial
that he's not going to be like gunning
for the next opportunity i could be
wrong but i think that's true i don't
think he's going to get any easy shots
in like that no i think if in a few
months or in a couple years there's
another similar event in some other you
know antioch illinois or whatever some
equivalent place that's driving distance
from where he is
i i would be surprised if he chooses to
show up to guard a business with an
ar-15 quite frankly
yeah ridden house the written house
inning two i don't i don't think i'm
ready for that one i think i need a bit
of a break i it's i'm interested in
seeing how things go i mean best case
scenario is that he stays out of stuff
and just lives a regular life from now
on which you know i think would be ideal
but
obviously the talking points from the
trial will remain you know i know you
don't do debates as often i guess as i
do but
when you see conservatives say you know
like the liberal media lied about this
that or the other what do you what do
you say to that like what talking points
do you have how do you plan to address
that what will probably be years of
accusations of of bias right now i have
no i mean i i've not talked to anyone
who has really
asked me to address that i mean my
audience knows i i basically don't watch
corporate media other than specific
things that
i plan to talk about on my show
and i also don't even really remember
the coverage from the beginning of it so
i mean if it becomes an omnipresent
thing to use your term i will have to
think about that uh but i just don't
even
i don't know i mean it's it's just not a
conversation i've even had up to this
time
okay that's fair
to go back to the white supremacy thing
though to go back a little bit because i
didn't want to get away from that too
immediately the issue i have with that
is
you can always say
that on some level that's the
explanation and it's essentially an
indefeasible argument um and i'm
reminded of there's this recent um
there's this like a local story that a
couple people i know were involved in
related to an art show and the idea was
like hey you know we're gonna have an
art show but in order to prevent
possible bias
on the basis of the identity of the
artists everything will be blind judged
so nobody will know the identity of the
artists great
um and then there was without getting
into the exact details there was like a
reaction about
the
rankings for the pieces of art where
people started saying you know even
though it was blind
you had an a jury in the art show that
was all white and that's reflected in
their choices and then later it came out
actually most of the art jury were
minorities so it wasn't actually that
and then the next argument became well
but they were privileged minorities and
one of them went to harvard and so their
perspective
is still emblematic so it's like
well
you you're never going to be satisfied
that it was anything other than that and
and it seems sort of like a similar
thing to what you're talking about
right right completely non-falsifiable i
think there are times where you can make
that argument fairly like for example
the ahmad arbory case the police not
charging until public pressure mounted
yes i am very comfortable saying that
you know
i can't say you know any one of the cops
are like clan members or nothing you
know nothing particularly direct but
that absolutely feels like something
which warrants a criticism uh along
those lines but you you could apply
anything anywhere anytime and you see
people applying it in instances where
it's entirely unwarranted uh if it's
non-falsifiable you have to have a
really good way of using it or a really
good reason to use it otherwise you
could just sort of
throw it out there blindly like like for
instance i mean you know we've kind of
seen the opposite a little bit i think
conservatives are really interested in
getting kind of like
a comeuppance to the ahmad arbory
verdict that um wisconsin
is is it being called a terror attack
when they drove into that um
well i think the right is definitely
calling it that although i i mean it may
be the right term for it
yeah it might be i i don't know what
developments have been made on potential
motive i know the driver was a black guy
and i've been seeing people at least you
know people in my comments section of
response they were like well what are
you going to talk about this black guy
that killed these white people so i
think that they're they're looking to
invoke kind of the opposite i remember
after george floyd was murdered there
was that five-year-old white kid who was
killed by that random black guy it
wasn't racially motivated yes
yeah yeah and they were like where is
the justice for this five-year-old white
kid what do you care about floyd but not
about this and it was just like
the guy was caught he's going to jail
forever nobody was defending him you
know right that was the difference that
was the difference at the time which is
it was just there's no chance that
anybody's getting away with anything
here
yeah so there's nothing really to
prote i mean it's it's horrible of
course yeah
i feel like so much of the discourse
these days concerning criminal justice
and race relations is really just
waiting for the next highly publicized
murder
and
and seeing how the discourse evolves
around it it feels like the discourse
never evolves unless it's being
catalyzed by some horrible random act of
violence now along those lines
um the things that
i have been more you know it's like
there's i don't know how much you're
aware but like for example
the community around stephen kenneth
destiny bennell ii has taken issue with
my perspective on the written house
trial and
some others anecdotally have and i've
continued to say
for me it looks like
the facts point to totally plausible
self-defense as an argument and i expect
not guilty for me the bigger concern
here is
that this is all part of the unique
american gun culture where guns are
seeing as a seen as a sort of totally
normal and sensible way to to solve
problems and that uh this event in
principle was not really problematic
with all the people carrying the you
know is it like the parenting can you
imagine what would have happened if when
i was 16 or 17
any of my parents had gotten hold that i
was thinking of even going to such an
event never mind going armed never mind
you know i'm gonna go protect the
business like there's so many other
layers to this you know
yeah i um no no no i i completely agree
the issue and i think legal eagle put
out a great video that talks about this
is that self-defense is not even close
to being a good metric for responsible
social behavior where sometimes you have
situations where a group of people can
act somewhat irresponsibly and you have
an escalated searing of self-defense
killings until the last man standing is
the one that gets the not guilty verdict
uh the the you can't
the idea that something is self-defense
or like justified self-defense is not in
any way like a holistic moral
exoneration of their behavior especially
with i mean you get cases like this
sometimes there was one that i saw um
where i think it was a gas station
attendant was being robbed uh at
gunpoint and the gas station attendant
actually disarmed the the robber and and
pointed the gun back at the rubber and
then a passing police officer who saw
through the window one man pointing a
gun at the other shot
the the gas station uh guy you know if
you're in a movie theater one person
starts shooting the second person shoots
in self-defense now there are two people
shooting yeah it's it gets really tough
to judge these situations and that's why
i hate the whole vigilante mob violence
response you know just
marauding through the nighttime streets
as rioters and looters sort of gallivant
around like this is you're maximizing
the likelihood of violence here it's not
about protection it doesn't protect
anything agreed yeah and i don't know if
you remember that i mean when you
mentioned the movie theater i'm guessing
you're alluding to the aurora batman
movie theater incident right
yeah oh yeah and in that but i mean
broadly too like just imagine being in
that situation that you hear like
gunshots coming from either side of the
room like right right well i guess my
point was going to be at the time i
don't know if you remember there were
people saying the problem is that the
movie theaters are gun-free zones and
there weren't armed people there
and then you say well hold on a second
you're saying if there had been
additional shooters in the dark theater
it would have been better and then they
usually will retreat to well no if it's
known that it's not a gun-free zone the
shooter wouldn't have attempted this
there in the first place which seems to
completely ignore that a lot of these
public shooting incidents are not people
thinking clearly in that way anyway you
know
they're going there to die they a lot of
these people expect to be suicided by
cops they're not going to be deterred by
the knowledge that one in 100 people
might have brought their glock to a to a
batman screening right i i really agree
though about the the sort of the
sociological implications because if if
you want to take like a really deep
personalized stance i think that
rittenhouse ultimately is a victim of a
lot of um social
tendencies yeah here here in the states
gun culture being a huge part you know
the obsession with and this is like a
long-standing conservative thing you
know uh racial protests are leading to
violence in the streets our civilization
is being destabilized we need strong
people out there with guns this
narrative has been around since before
the civil rights movement but it always
ends in violence it's possible to
believe that too with not a drop of
racism in your body you know you can
believe that totally race neutrally but
it's a way of getting sometimes
non-racist people
in line with sort of the the systemic
uh
you know
white supremacist tendency you know you
know what i mean absolutely and i wonder
i mean
the the the problem is that when you say
what's the full conclusion to this it's
everybody would be safest if just
everybody had a gun
and unfortunately like under the
paradigm we have
in which people can obtain firearms
and all of the specifics that only leads
to a lot of people
who currently don't have guns and have
violent impulses having the same
impulses plus the guns in more
situations and so they see the logical
conclusion as once everybody's armed no
one would ever shoot anybody because you
know everybody's armed and you'll end up
getting shot but it's like they already
know they're likely to end up getting
shot and it doesn't deter them now
yeah they they they clearly don't i i
was um
i was actually present at a shooting
once you know oh really uh
at santa monica college back in 20 i
don't know something 13 there was uh
there was a shooting there at the
library just outside of it while i was
further in and the guy uh you know came
there i think to be suicided by cops
that's always how the sense right they
very rarely get captured alive the the
whole an armed society is a polite
society thing is absolute [ __ ] it's
mathematically disprovable
don't get me wrong i'm a huge uh you
know proponent of gun rights i have six
guns uh just just off to my right right
now um
but there's a huge difference between
gun ownership and gun culture and the
gun culture thing the idea that guns are
like this you know
valuable
weapon of you know social righteousness
they're an extension of your masculinity
they'll solve any problem you will be
attacked every day of your life if
you're not armed that [ __ ] that
paranoid fear-mongering that's i think
the critical issue you know the swiss
have plenty of guns in their households
but they're all you know
ex-military training you know kept clean
stored up in the attic type deals no
it's just it's quite simple if you ask
the swiss
do you see guns
as maybe being the way to solve
a social political or interpersonal
problem
the answer would be
almost a hundred percent no
whereas if you poll people in the u.s
and there was recently a poll done here
more general it didn't say guns but it
said violence but i'm sure if you
repeated the poll with guns
a lot more people in the u.s believe
that at least on some of those
interpersonal political or social guns
are a valid way to solve that problem so
you take that perspective among some
people and you combine it with a ton of
guns it's not shocking what the outcome
is going to be
yeah or or people who think that having
a gun in your house will make you safer
it won't mathematically you're not going
to stop a burglar or a robber or
whatever that's not going to happen or
people who think open carry makes like
community safer or people think
concealed carry is like like you'll be
mugged like every other week you know
it's it's it's nonsense but people
believe this down in their in their gut
i mean down to their core i i'll just
say by the way because otherwise my my
commie friends you know they'll get mad
at me the big thing that i that i
advocate for
with regards to guns is i know that
we've got a ton of guns in this country
and i know a ton of them are held
by people with whom i share tremendous
political disagreements and if if things
get bad in this country you know really
destabilized
20 50 years i don't know whatever in the
future i would think it nice
if
relatively progressive city communities
were armed and not just the right-wing
militias that would start patrolling the
streets the moment they got the chance
you know yeah yeah i so i've my audience
knows like i've said before i don't
really talk about my
gun ownership or lack thereof or i just
don't see any real advantage to making
it a personal thing but i've said that
over the last few years
many of my progressive friends have
started
legally arming themselves and the reason
they cite is
i don't want the right wingers having
all the guns or being the only ones with
guns that's the number one reason they
cite many of them don't particularly
like shooting guns they're not target
practice people they don't believe that
in terms of armed robberies or whatever
they're going to be statistically safer
because they but they say if we play
this out and the right is the only
political side that's armed that seems
bad and that's the number one reason
they are pursuing firearm ownership
totally agree i think that's a really
honorable reason you know if you if you
don't want it in the house because you
feel like you got like a mental health
risk or anything like that like you keep
with a friend it's just that i think the
broader deterrent is valuable is will
will some lunatic with an ar-15 refrain
from shooting up at denny's because six
of the people in there might be
concealed carrying probably not right
but if an entire city is generally known
to be full of gun owners you know
somewhere in their house will that maybe
deter potential destabilizing militia
action maybe it could i don't know
possibly it we have to have something
right i don't know yeah i guess i don't
know but i agree with you that at the
individual crime level at least right
now it doesn't seem to be a factor
that's taken into consideration when
people decide about committing
particular uh particular crimes now that
being said
um i do think it's
relevant i guess to mention
that i don't think that there's much
advantage to democrats at essentially
any level
of talking about guns and gun safety
because it seems to only hurt them in in
any election that i've seen i'm curious
what you think about that not i'm not a
democrat i don't know to what extent you
even care about democrats winning
particular elections but it seems to me
that democrats talking about
uh guns makes it a voting issue for the
right to come out and say we've got to
protect our gun rights by voting against
this person
yes i really wish they would shut up
please god beta or work is the last
thing we need there are so many
independence libertarians and even
moderate republicans who are generally
decent people who are terrified of the
government taking their guns there is no
reason to keep biting this bullet you
don't even have to go big pro gun just
shut up about it i just don't think
democrats yeah yeah democrats aren't
going to not vote for biden if biden
doesn't really talk about the guns you
know just just lay off you know some
simple oh i support our second member
rights then shut up about it uh it's
it's insane to me it's it's borderline
like they want to lose there are so many
people that are
practically second amendment hardliners
i just don't know why anyone would would
waste political capital on this and it
never even comes to anything what gun
regulations have we had meaningfully in
this country the last big one was the
bump stock ban but like really there are
hundreds of millions of guns we're never
going to ban all of those what points
they're even trying i agree i agree and
um i i even mentioned this in the
context of beta running and the clip
from the democratic debate in 20 2020
right he just ran i mean it feels like
so long ago i guess it was 2020 where he
was asked wait so are you saying you
would like take people's ar-15s and
ak-47s and he like pauses and says yes
and it's like that's not gonna help him
in running for governor in texas at all
no in texas of all places i i don't know
i mean i guess it's a branding thing i
just i don't i'm just i'm not that
afraid of guns you know because the
attitudes that make people dangerous
when they hold guns are dangerous when
they're not holding them either way you
know the the the but they're able to do
more damage if they are holding guns oh
oh absolutely don't get me wrong yeah
guns do not help but with hundreds of
millions of guns in the country i'm not
like holding my breath for a total
removal um you know maybe if we were
japan and we had like no guns in the
country this would be a different
talking point but like you know if you
have your average like q and on nut
they're probably going to hurt me not
through some sporadic shooting in a
theater they're probably going to hurt
me by voting for politicians that are
going to i don't know criminalize being
gay or whatever do the q people even
vote i mean that's a different question
but they have to with with marjorie
taylor green types in in the republican
party i feel like they've got to be at
least somewhat invigorated yeah that's
probably probably true i guess we'll see
in 2022 i mean the thing is a lot of
them are in safe red districts anyway so
even without like the q contingent
they'll still win
that's true yeah though though you know
they'll in in the primaries you know
they'll vote in the crazier reds i think
um
it's it's really a shame how the
hardliner republicans are evangelical
boomers who will like vote they they
like put you know on their calendar
they'll mark off the voting day but the
hard-line lefties in this country are
all like bordega you know krapotkin
readers who believe in anti-electoralism
and won't even get out of bed for like
voting out trump it's pretty it's pretty
annoying
yeah i uh i don't know
do you have a sense of whether like
okay so in 2022 a bunch of them will get
reelected just because they're in safe
districts and there's a few additional q
people that are running in 22 but like
if trump doesn't run in 24 do you think
that this like cue trump movement just
goes away or do they become integrated
into the republican party the way the
tea party did
i think i think it becomes fully
integrated i mean even if trump did
something spectacularly bad they've made
you know jfk jr like a legacy movement
member in spite of him never having
anything to do with anything right
um
because like the the attitude doesn't go
away republicans the politicians i mean
i feel like they're terrified of their
voters there was recently those um that
whistleblower from facebook who said
that at least in europe i mean the the
info was from europe but i think this is
universally applicable there were far
right political parties who move further
to the right to match the increasingly
radical views
of their constituencies so i i feel like
the snowball's rolling down the hill at
that point you know you can take
desantis to take up the the torch if you
want but
unfortunately i think we're going to
need some kind of reconstruction tier
social realignment to really fix this
yes speaking of which i mean for people
in my audience who may not know you are
an actual bona fide socialist not you
know someone wrongly called a socialist
how is the fight for socialism going in
your mind
why would you ask me that you know you
know what i'm going why would you do
that uh
look the the the the primary
goal of any socialist first and foremost
should be anti-fascism uh lenin allied
with uh social democrat groups to fight
against the fascists the thousand knives
in russia uh mao stopped fighting with
the um you know with with the um the
conservatives to fight off japan uh back
in the uh you know back in the 1930s
and they weren't even good socialists
like me i i just i think that
the the the goal the black hundreds not
the thousands thank you the the the goal
first and foremost is i think right now
dealing with the republican party and i
think you can do that in ways which are
more or less advantageous for you know i
guess my long-term ideological goals um
but to be honest
we're not really in a position to build
anything right now outside of maybe the
little spattering of a labor movement
we've we've we've got presently i guess
we can kindle that little fire like that
little
you know match light to keep the wind
from blowing it out apart from that
though just keeping this country from
spiraling into nothing would be a good
uh
good
that's that's interesting to me because
my my perception of you is you're not
really like a tanky socialist in a very
particular sense and i mean correct me
if i'm wrong but um i was talking to uh
my dad the other day and i don't know if
you know but like i'm from argentina my
parents grew up in argentina in the 60s
70s where there was like the equivalent
to the current tanki movement they loved
fidel castro and so on and so forth and
um
one of the things i was talking to my
dad about was this contingent in the
left now
that sometimes sort of almost sounds
right-wing like without naming anybody
in particular like they often like
authoritarians like putin and castro and
others they you know whatever you know
the full kind of like package of the
thing and what my dad said was
for him this is such an old playbook
it's the exact same thing that he was
seeing
among
the argentinean tanki left in the late
60s and early 70s that it's no it's not
a new thing it's that there's always
been this contingent of the so-called
left and he was close to that like in in
argentina he was part of like a jew what
was called a jewish socialist movement
and um it was very different than the
people who like the russian and all the
different stuff
what's your purse are you part of that
group or what's your perception of that
group it seems to me that you're not
part of that group
well um
with
i i i feel like um
uh i'm trying i'm trying to think of the
most measured way of of putting this i
i feel like a lot of people are looking
for a kind of social rebirth uh that
people when they're desperate or when
they don't have much going for them
they're looking for some kind of direct
meaningful movement that they think will
radically change everything they don't
like about the world okay and those
people are usually um
tankies or fascists uh where i'm not
this isn't an argument against
revolutionary action but rather it's
this they they need this um they have an
emotional attachment to this you know um
epigenesis this massive social revival
but then there are people who approach
their political project
um in in i guess what i'd consider to be
a more decentralized way where it's not
really about the direct attachment to
that process or its outcomes but about
the
the the principles that you you try to
meet on your way there historically in
every major socialist revolution you've
seen these two groups fight and one of
them win and it's almost always the
authoritarians after lenin won the
worker councils which he relied on for
the first 18 or so months of the soviet
union were quickly disbanded their
members killed or sent to siberia uh you
know uh in mao's china you had a similar
situation the students were weaponized
against the um the teachers and all the
old guard were killed off and then
eventually the students were sent off to
the farms there's this happens time and
time again it's it's deeply unfortunate
and i think the ultimate issue is that
it's just way easier to be authoritarian
it's so much easier it's way easier you
get a military together you entrust
everything to a glorious leader and you
trust them to enact these principles but
this just doesn't work it's the reason
why sometimes they come off a little bit
less i guess revolutionary than other
people who believe in such a thing i
think you need to lay the right
groundwork you have to make sure the
material conditions are ripe the working
class needs to be the agent of its own
emancipation with revolutionaries only
being a tool to be used by the working
class if you do the opposite where the
working class is a tool to be used by
the revolutionaries you get a repeat of
you know 100 years of failed socialism
they're just uh you know an angry mob to
be weaponized until you can appoint a
new elite cast of political agents yeah
i mean in our last conversation and i'm
getting the sense now you believe in a
more uh i guess what we would call a
gradual transition to the system you
believe is the ideal system
yeah rather than a revolutionary
transition
my guess is we're not really gonna have
a choice this is my guess i don't know
this of course but i think climate
change is going to get bad enough uh
that we're going to deal with economic
downturn resource um you know uh um
shortages uh and climate refugees and
that this is going to lead to enough
destabilization that america and a bunch
of other countries are going to have
like internal crises over what to do and
at that point it's either going to be
like some kind of
you know fascist government or something
more radical more left-leaning i think
at that point we're not going to have a
choice like things are getting really
bad there so for me it's just about
laying the bricks until you reach that
point
you're not like a cia or anything right
i not to my knowledge uh as as many
times i've been accused of saying
um okay couple other things i i wanted
to ask you um uh hold on now i oh do you
know so
who is mr beast and what did he do in
the last 48 hours that people are going
crazy about
he's a big youtuber um a very big one uh
kind of philanthropic he reinvests a lot
of his money into the projects that he
does uh you know like we're all stranded
on an island person to find this
treasure gets a billion dollars or
whatever he's made a recreation of squid
game have you seen squid game i'm i'm
aware of it
you should see it it's good he's
recreating it he built all the sets you
know oh really is mean like in real life
yeah yeah it got 400 or so people i
don't think they're uh spoilers i don't
think they're killing the people brought
on board okay uh the way they did in the
um in the show proper but um i could be
wrong i actually haven't seen it okay
all right i'm gonna it's so it's so it's
actually something worth being aware of
oh oh yeah oh squid game was lovely i
really really enjoyed it i just mean
this whole mr beast like version of it
probably i've seen screenshots and i've
seen little video clips and i'm probably
going to watch it either today or
tomorrow because it does look pretty
funny it's actually going to be the
first mr beast video i've ever seen so
okay fair uh new to me now here's the
other thing as a socialist i wanted to
ask you your thoughts on a debate i was
having with my audience earlier and i
think you're going to be uniquely
positioned to weigh in on this
do you believe absolutely that tesla's
inexperience with building vehicles
is going to slowly allow legacy
companies like audi porsche and mercedes
to chip away at tesla's electric vehicle
market share by virtue of simply being
better at building nice cars
unironically yes absolutely i recently
watched a video which linked to a few
articles talking about how tesla's cars
are not particularly well designed or
well-priced tesla is unique mostly in
making them cool um i don't think that
elon musk is a competent businessman uh
outside of the marketing element i think
that in terms of actually like a
sustainable long-term functioning
product he over-prioritizes glitz and
glam and under-prioritizes like
long-term
sensible investment um
and
and i i think very little of the man but
no really like electric cars have been
around for what nearly a century um and
there are cheaper and better electric
cars in the market they're just not
teslas i think that once the hype wears
off and it will eventually
it you know nothing like this stays
around forever i think other companies
are going to surge back and they're
going to be able to sort of scavenge the
clout that that tesla's carved out i
tend to agree i'm going to be i am both
an owner of stock and of a vehicle
and i am going to slowly uh start
disassociating from the stock slowly bit
by bit
um and i'm looking very strong i mean
here's here's the thing here's what
makes it very inconvenient to have any
non-tesla electric vehicle right now
the range of teslas is still the best
and
the fast charging network makes it
really difficult to do long trips with
any other vehicle
yeah it's the it's the infrastructure
you lay down if you're the first one to
really capture or corner the market you
can edge other people out and force them
you know to yeah so hopefully um
i don't know hopefully we could um
oh man can you imagine if there was
legislation on that so that like all the
tesla charging stations were retrofitted
so that they're universally usable yes
the problem is then a lot of them have
eight a lot of them only have eight to
twelve stalls
then
it's there's not an if if they were open
i'm not saying don't do it i think that
that would allow me to much more easily
look at other types of electric vehicles
because i know i could use the fast
charger but
those fast chargers would be permanently
full if they were open to every electric
vehicle just the reality
yeah i think um i mean i'm a big
advocate for public transport it's not
really relevant to this convo because
you and i are probably not going to be
taking buses everywhere but
i guess that'd be kind of nice long term
i i feel like um
the the dream
would be um
would be that you could have this kind
of thing at your house wouldn't it i
mean every house has an electric
you know current running to it if there
was some way to like commercially be
like here for 150 bucks here's a a you
know a an install you can get uh there's
a cord that like plugs out through the
garage you just pull it out and there
you go you're charging no they do i mean
that basically exists it's a little more
than than
i mean listen you know i don't know how
much we want to get into this but with
if you just have a regular plug without
having any electrical work done you get
a cable with your car and you can charge
it the thing is it'll only charge like
four to five miles per hour which is
very slow
you can then put in like a dryer plug a
240 volt that'll get you like 35 40
miles per hour
and that's what i have but you got to
pay an electrician to put that in unless
you're gonna run it all the way up to
wherever your dryer is you know but but
i think the the bigger issue is when
traveling away from home
yeah yeah that tracks i think um i mean
the goal would be
that uh we would um
we would only use these cars in
you know short distance travel i think
right at least when i think of like a
good sustainable electric infrastructure
future you know you have your car for
like picking up groceries in the city
but if you want to travel like far far
you know you've got uh robust train or
subway networks you get there there are
local options i think that'd be quite
nice yeah yeah i mean in practical terms
we just don't have that you know if you
want to go if you're in new york city
and you want to go to as i recently did
a wedding in maine
um
maybe you could take a train but it
might take 30 hours because you've got
to go to maybe montreal first i don't
even know how you would do it uh
obviously that's lacking right now
yeah well we can always dream of the
future sure there are a few channels i'm
really really fond of um adam's
something does a couple of videos making
fun of um tesla and elon musk in in in
reasonable ways i mean you know
critiquing the technology and uh not
just bikes talks about sustainable
infrastructure and i love both of them
very much european cities are so
wonderfully designed compared to our own
so livable
um it's one of the reasons i like
seattle there are portions of seattle
where everyone's always walking not
because there's no parking but more so
because there's such a robust mix of
residential and commercial zoning that
there's always something interesting to
do in the area
speaking of seattle by the way i don't
know how devastating this was to you i'm
guessing that up until recently
you were likely the biggest
seattle-based youtuber but with the
arrival of jay kenji lopez alt in
seattle who has i believe one of the
best youtube channels in the cooking
space
i think that that may have knocked you
down a peg i don't know if you're aware
of that
no no it's it's good for me um if if i
can never sort of um you know find my
way on set during a recording or you
know throw a rock through the window try
to like get my name on it you know i i
it opens up opportunities for um cloud
sharking on my part that i'm really
looking forward to wait am i even wrong
on that is kenji in portland oregon now
i don't remember i know he's up in the
pacific northwest somewhere what i said
may have been completely wrong now i'm
not even oh i don't even know who you're
referring to i don't even know
gotcha i'm just i'm just working with it
the the only the only cooking youtubers
that i've enjoyed are binging with
babish and the um
um
the uh that one big corporate one that
everyone stopped watching because there
were accusations of racism from the
manager god what was that called oh i
don't know that one i don't know
um
bon appetit
and then they all often made their own
youtube channels no my favorite song i
am kenji and jacques
it is indeed yeah
okay actually he's cuban would you
believe that
well no if it came from you yeah if it
came from a less reputable source though
you gotta you gotta watch yourself you
know i believe anything you say no he is
french i believe he's from lyon or
something like that uh oh and also
toontoon for thai cooking you can't beat
toontoon
he's getting me cultured over here you
know i'm really more of a chicken
nuggies guy myself so we're we're we're
branching out of my comfort zone a
little bit do you not cook for your
tenants either i'm sorry roommates
okay okay i i work and i pay the rent
okay these these these [ __ ] can cook
from time to time no we we we really we
really don't make that much we get those
um what do you call them hellofresh yeah
uh what we're like like 12 meals a week
split between the three of us you know
um and those are really good by the way
i was taken away because they you know
they deliver it and then it's like in a
box for a bit i thought it'd be like
so-so some of the meals that i've had
there are legitimately
the
uh
some of the best food i've ever had i
can't promote them though though because
apparently they did some union busting
recently oh wow i didn't hear about that
everyone ignore what i yeah are you for
or against spatchcocking when you do a
chicken on the grill
spatchcocking um you're gonna you're
gonna have to help me give me give me a
brief description it's basically you
butterfly the chicken to make it the
same thickness throughout in order to
have even cooking
uh yes yes you have to cut you have to
cut it down also the the best
the best cut of chicken okay is about a
half an inch okay you you you you cut it
in half you smash the chicken a half an
inch deep that's the perfect chicken cut
right there a half inch deep
like yeah like the thickness is about a
half an inch uh once you've flattened or
butterflied the chicken breast right oh
you're talking about chicken breast
oh are you talking about thighs i'm
talking about the entire chicken
oh
i see no i've never hammered an entire
chicken down into a pasty no no you
don't need a hammer you don't need a
hammer at all
listen i'm gonna leave you to the to
investigating spatchcocking and i'm sure
you'll have a strong position on it by
the next time we talk
oh i'm sure i'll i'll learn i'll give it
a shot you know i'll i'll share my
success or failure story with you but
your idea of just smashing a full
chicken into a paste is an interesting
one i've never considered it but i might
it's it's how owls eat things okay just
sort of grind it up into a into a you
know a little
pellet it's it's been a pleasure
speaking with you thank you for taking
the time ian vosh uh a gentleman and a
scholar great to speak to you as always
david mann peck pacman you take care
enjoy the stream and uh i'll talk to you
eventually all right very good take care
there it is folks uh world renowned
streamer ian vosh very good take care
there